so now we're going to do yokomonucci
and
the hand shapes again so Danny
so they come
you're coming you can either come in
here
bring the hand down but look what's
happened now
naturally
you got that thumb where it needs to be
and that one comes over
but sometimes techniques
rather than in if I was to go now round
sometimes this one gets in the way and
this one goes on top and if you always
remember the one closest to him
is at the bottom
the one closest to him is at the bottom
so we're gonna do not the one that's
natural and works out
easy for you
we're going to do the one that you've
got to think about you put the thumb
in the right place so you've got to
place that thumb
here yeah
yeah okay
it's up to you whether you take a camera
or not